how much can landing in snow protect you
from the fall well we've seen it save
people who jumped off a roof or dived
off a cliff
and yes even who fell from the top of a
mountain but what about a fall from even
higher up like from an airplane how much
snow would be required to break that
kind of fall what kind of snow would be
the best to fall into and how should you
position your body for a safe landing
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell from an airplane into
snow okay what if is if you're planning
on jumping out of an airplane without a
parachute you might want to check out
our video on what happens if you die
because that's what you'd have to look
forward to the math changes depending on
how much you weigh but let's imagine
that you weigh 65 kilograms as you fall
from an airplane that's thousands of
meters in the air your body would travel
at a velocity of 55 meters per second
and when you smash into the solid ground
below that velocity would instantly drop
to zero meters per second causing
catastrophic injuries but if there was a
whole bunch of snow on top of that solid
ground it might be enough to save you
from dying don't believe me well it's
happened before
in 1972 a serbian flight attendant named
vesna vulovic survived the mid-air
explosion of a jetliner after plummeting
hundreds of meters through some trees
and landing on a snowy hill yeah she
broke her legs pelvis some vertebrae and
fractured her skull but if a little snow
could save her life then why not yours
but let's not get too confident here
because there are still a ton of ways
that this could go completely wrong if
you're going to survive you'll need a
bunch of factors to line up perfectly
the key to surviving a fall from an
airplane is to make your deceleration
last as long as possible okay math again
if you weigh 65 kilograms and fall six
kilometers you'd be heading down to
earth at a velocity of 55 meters per
second if you land on solid ground and
you only decelerate for half a second
you'll hit with a force of 7.1
kilonewtons if you're not a math teacher
or a scientist that's 726 kilograms but
if you were able to stretch that
deceleration out by even the smallest of
a mouse it could make a world of
difference for example even stretching
the deceleration time out to one second
would reduce the force to 356 kilograms
and if you decelerate for two seconds it
would be 183 kilograms
landing in a nice bed of snow could
definitely help you slow down enough to
save you but it would have to be the
right type of snow the snow would need
to be able to compress slowing your fall
- less than 98 meters per second squared
so the snow must be thick enough for
this to occur about 80 meters
the reason why you need to travel at
less than 98 meters per second square is
that this is ten times the force of
gravity the approximate acceleration
that humans can make without too much
damage
so considering all this
you'd better cross your fingers that
you'll be landing in lots of soft fresh
snow because of its lower density fresh
dry snow can be compressed more and
soften your landing pack snow and wet
snow are denser than fresh and dry snow
so they can't be compacted as much and
wouldn't extend your deceleration enough
to save you but even if you're 100
percent sure that the snow you're
landing in is fresh deep and dry you're
still not out of the danger zone to give
yourself the best chance at survival
you're going to want to land in a
belly-flop that may seem strange but it
would actually be the safest choice you
see if you land feet first all of your
weight will press down on that small
area but if you land on your belly your
weight will be more evenly distributed
so you won't be hurt as badly now if by
some chance you happen to survive the
landing without too many injuries you're
going to have to dig your way out of the
snow as you can imagine falling all the
way down from an airplane would be
pretty disorienting so your first step
for getting out of the snow would be to
figure out which way is up one helpful
trick that I always use is to drool a
little and see which direction it slides
down your face the opposite of that is
upwards
of course this is all easier said than
done in reality there's a reason we've
only heard of one person who's ever
survived falling out of a plane because
it's very unlikely to happen unless
you've found some way to obtain
immortality but that's a story for
another whatever
[Music]